I'll take a look at
the smaller layout first.
Box A takes up 50% of the viewport,
and has an order of negative 1,
which looks like it's the lowest
meaning box A comes first, but
probably means the Red Box is box A.
Container 2 has a width of 50% and
no order.
So, I think it's probably a good
guess that container 2 is
talking about the light blue and
the green divs.
I can see that boxB must
come after boxA, and
because this doesn't have an order,
it's probably order 0,
so that means that boxB is
going to be the Dark Blue Box.
That probably means
the Green Box is boxC.
But, I want to take up the larger
viewport to confirm my suspicions.
I can see that boxC has an order of
negative 1 in the larger viewport,
which means that it looks like
it's going to come first.
That's a pretty good argument
that the Green Box is boxC,
but let’s just goes ahead and make sure.
Box B has a width of 25%,
and an order of 2.
Which is the largest one I see here,
so it's probably going to come last.
Well that seems to make sense, because I
said that the Dark Blue Box is boxB, and
here boxB seems to be the last one.
BoxA is 25% and comes right before boxB.
Which makes it the red one.
So, I'm feeling pretty good about
my answer that the Red Box is boxA.
And lastly, there's still this
container class with a width of 50%.
And it looks like it's still being
applied to the light blue, and
the green boxes.
So, in the end, boxA is Red,
boxC is Green, and boxB is Dark Blue.